Hey, everybody.
I'm Andrew [? Broggan. ?] And
welcome back to the Mobile Ads
Garage, where videos
of mobile ads code
arrive just like old
batteries-- free of charge.
In our last episode, we covered
how to implement interstitials
in iOS and Android.
Today, with the help of
Gary the Graphics Guy,
we're going to show
you the best ways
to use them by focusing
on where, when, and how.
One of most important things
to consider with interstitial
is where you're
going to show them
within the flow of your app.
Ideally, you're looking for a
natural break in the action.
Between levels in a
game is a great one.
Switching between
articles or activities
is another good spot.
You're looking for places where
the user is expecting a pause.
If they're not in
a hurry, they're
more likely to consider
what the ad has to say
and they're less likely
to feel interrupted.
That's important,
because you never
want to disrupt
the user right when
they're trying-- [SIGH]
--trying to do something.
Dude, Buckets o' Cheeze?
I think that would
give me hypertension.
Picking pauses in the action
for your interstitials
can also help keep you in
line with AdMob's publisher
policies.
For example, to
make sure users are
able to identify which
app is showing them an ad,
an interstitial should never
be the very first thing
they see when launching your app
or the last thing on exiting.
Another thing that can set a
good spot apart from a bad one
is user expectation.
For example, if you had a game
in which people tap like crazy
on the screen,
make sure you don't
show an interstitial
right when they
think a new game is starting.
They could end up tapping on
the ad accidentally, which
is a bad clickthrough.
Just like we talked in
our episode about banners,
it's a part of a
publisher's job to make
sure people don't
accidentally tap on ads
when they're trying
to do something else.
So that's the where part.
Now let's talk when.
When is mostly a
question of how often.
There's a balance to find
between showing enough ads
that you can hit
your revenue goals,
but not so many that you
flood your user with ads.
Are you dissatisfied with
your current shampoo?
No.
Thank you.
Want to see a movie about
a cat that plays chess?
It's called "Checkmeow."
I'm all set, really.
Even if it's something the
user might be interested in--
Dude, cupcakes in the hallway.
Cupcakes in the hallway.
-it's just too much.
Is your dog getting
enough fiber?
I got to start shaving
my neck beard better.
If the flow of your
app is dominated
by one screen or activity, it's
easy to keep track and avoid
this kind of thing.
Imagine an app with
multiple activities, though.
If you show an interstitial
every time the user switches,
a new user who's
poking around the app
might end up seeing a whole
lot of ads very quickly.
On the plus side, this is
an easy problem to fix.
You can keep a
time stamp of when
the last interstitial
was shown to make
sure you don't overdo it.
Or you could only show
an ad every other time
the user switches activities.
And so on.
All right.
So that's where and when,
which just leaves us with how.
The big thing I want
to touch on here
is how to make sure you
have an interstitial ready
when you need one.
You might remember these
steps from our last episode.
Interstitials are
bigger than banners,
and can take a little
extra time to load.
So they're requested
asynchronously,
before they're needed.
You can start that process
pretty much as early
as you want in order to
make sure you're done
loading when the time comes.
The important thing is that
the ad waits for the user,
so the user never
waits for the ad.
I don't know about you, but the
last thing I ever want to do
is sit around as-- [BEEPING]
Oh, for the love
of-- Home button.
So make sure you give your
app enough time for its ad
requests.
Even if that means
you sometimes load
an interstitial that you don't
end up displaying, that's fine.
So now you know the
where, when, and how.
That's all for this episode.
Here are some links to our
interstitial guidance pages,
which have some great tips
on how to use interstitials
effectively.
And don't forget to check
out AdMob's no-nonsense guide
to app monetization.
It's an overview of
monetization strategies
that includes code and
tips from other engineers.
As always, if you've got a
technical question relating
to anything you've just seen,
stop by our support forum.
And if you've got a question
about this video series
or an idea for something
we could cover,
leave a comment below, and Gary
and I will see you next time.
So you want to go check
out those cupcakes now?
Yes.
Yes, I would.
[MUSIC PLAYING]